hi it's michelle of lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd and cosmetic
chemist and today we're going to go
through my teenage skin care routine
yes a lot of the products were horrifying
if you like nerding out about the science
behind beauty products click like
subscribe and the nerdification bell
i'm turning 35 this year which
means i grew up in the 2000s
the 2000s were a time of britney flared jeans
butterfly clips and some really cringy skincare
despite some really cringe moments i think overall
in hindsight it was actually quite a nice time you
had a bit more breathing room between apocalyptic
events so here is what i look like in the 2000s
i went through a lot of regrettable years when
i didn't have a fringe i sort of was channeling
the middle-aged accountant vibe you can also tell
it was like the height of my trichotillomania
i was doing a lot of hair pulling and you
can see the hair regrowth is a bit warped
so what skin care was teenage michelle using
firstly i was using the avon invigorating scrub
my dad bought this when i started getting
pimples and it's kind of exactly what
you'd expect a clueless dad to buy this was
bright blue it had scrubbing particles in
it which were shaped like shards like they were
literally triangles it was mentholated to death
and yeah it was fresh to death it felt like you
were sandpapering your face and then dunking
your face in a bucket of ice water and this
was kind of what we assumed acne care should
have been at the time this was before the gospel
of paula of paula's choice our lord and savior
really took hold this was even before google took
hold we were searching things on like yahoo search
alta vista and ask jeeves we weren't going to find
paula i'm pretty confident this was way worse than
st ives apricot scrub to no one's surprise my
skin did not like this i actually remember the
skin on my nose going hard and stiff and cracking
and i remember trying to peel off the flakes with
a pair of tweezers and that was not good i ended
up with just a constantly scabby nose this was
dehydrating as hell and i have dehydration
prone skin so yeah this was not a happy
time you cannot successfully treat acne by just
scrubbing it and drying it out harsh treatments
will usually just make acne worse because one of
the contributing factors to acne is inflammation
now the next step in my teenage skin care journey
was clean and clear's three-step oil control pack
at the time clean and clear had this massive
campaign that was targeting teenagers they
would stick these little sample bottle packs
to the front of teenage music magazines i got
a bunch of different sets from this magazine
i used to buy called tv hits and i actually
remember buying this exact one it had 5ive
on the cover my best friend at the time
was obsessed with this boy band 5ive
and she made me give her the centerfold
we're not friends anymore for unrelated reasons
so looking this up based on the ingredients it
looks like the exact same formulas as i was
using 20 years ago are still available now
the packaging is exactly the same it doesn't
like they're sold in the us or the uk anymore
maybe they're just shunting the leftovers to
us australians because no one cares about us
okay the cleanser this ingredient list looks
nothing like anything else i've seen in a
really long time i think the way it's working is
they've got free fatty acids and triethanolamine
which is a base and by mixing that together
they basically make soap i remember this being
really foamy and for these soap surfactants
to foam well it'd have to be somewhere near
pH 8 or 9. it also has methylisothiazolinone
as a preservative this is MI and it's a pretty
common allergen it's only allowed in wash-off
products these days and you don't really see
it in face products that much anymore it is
reasonably common in shampoos and conditioners
my skin is generally pretty robust but this
particular ingredient and its cousin MCI
both make me really itchy and i wonder if i was
actually allergic to this product at the time
and i just didn't know i do remember this being
pretty stripping and we all thought back then
that stripping is good type means clean and a lot
of people still think this it's not true if you
feel tight after cleansing usually this means that
the proteins in your skin have changed their shape
they're denatured and since these proteins are
an essential part of your skin barrier that
means that your skin barrier is probably leaky
it's losing water and it's letting irritants in
now the toner this was a really blue alcoholic
toner this is basically paula's nightmare toner
these days toners are a lot better they're not
just dehydrating alcohol-laden products anymore
except apparently this one it's a pretty simple
formula it's got alcohol and salicylic acid it's
also got glycereth-26 which is emollient it's
sort of like a less effective version of glycerin
it's also got allantoin and panthenol which
are soothing and moisturizing ingredients which
i don't know if they're gonna help
given everything else in this formula
this was super watery so you had to apply it with
a cotton ball and i remember it stung so much and
the assumption was if it hurts it works
now the moisturizer this ingredient list actually
looks pretty similar to a lot of moisturizers
that we have on the market now and it's actually
kind of nice seeing all these parabens in there i
remember this being fine i remember i didn't
really use it that much because i had oily
skin and acne and the myth is if you have oily
skin and acne you don't need a moisturizer
i need a moisturizer i wonder if i would have had
an easier time getting into skincare if this had
glycerin in it it does have propylene glycol as
the second ingredient this is a humectant but
it's nowhere near as hydrating as glycerin my
skin is really dehydration prone and yeah this
moisturizer did not convince me that my skin
needed moisturizer if i was redesigning this
moisturizer i'd replace the propylene glycol with
glycerin and i would add sun protection to this i
think it doesn't have sun protection because it
has 0.5% salicylic acid and in the us that would
make it a drug and i don't think you're allowed
to have sunscreen and salicylic acid in the one
product we already have salicylic acid in the
toner anyway so i think getting rid of that
and putting in sun protection would be really
good as an introduction to teenage skin care
i also used clean and clear blotting
papers and these were also attached
to the front of a magazine these
actually look pretty much the same
as the ones i used when i was a teenager
i don't think they've really changed these
and yeah i think that's actually because they
were pretty good they're these light blue sheets
that you press down on your face they soak up
oil and you can see the blue plastic go clear
it's very satisfying it's a nice way of getting
rid of excess oil without irritating your skin
these are made of plastic though and these
days i use paper ones that i get from an asian
supermarket and they seem to soak up more oil as
well as being a bit more environmentally friendly
the next step up was when i actually bought my
own products instead of getting them off the
front of a magazine i was using cetaphil gentle
skin cleanser and nivea visage cleansing gel
i think these two products are where i got
my hate of cleansing over the sink from
the cedar fill was a gel product that didn't foam
so this one you could either put it on your face
and wash it off or you could actually put it on
your face and then wipe it off with a damp cloth
since my skin was oily i kind of felt like this
just didn't do much and i don't remember using it
more than a couple times i do remember the bottle
sitting in my bathroom for years so i think really
the problem here was that this just didn't match
my skin type now the nivea cleansing gel some not
very well formulated cleansers do this thing
where they stick onto your hand and they don't
really foam up so you'll put it in your hand
you'll try to foam it up you'll wash your face
you'll rinse off your face and then after all of
that you'll still have like a dollop of gel stuck
to the middle of your hand even these days there
are a few cleansers i've used that still do this
one is the inkey salicylic acid cleanser i don't
know why i kept on buying this even though it was
such a pain to use i think it might have just been
the cheapest cleanser from the supermarket but
this was actually quite hydrating it didn't strip
my skin it was just a little bit annoying to use
so onto the product that every teenager ends
up using benzoyl peroxide my first benzoyl
peroxide product was benzac 10% cream because
i decided to be a cheapass and i saw this stuff
online about how you should be using 2.5% but
i figured 10 divided by 4 if i just dilute that
i will end up with 2.5% of course the first
day i got lazy and instead of diluting it i
just sort of went i'll just put less on my face
and i put it all over my face i went to uni and
then in the middle of the day someone was like
michelle are you sunburned so basically the
benzoyl peroxide was really irritating and i think
it made my skin all so sensitive to the sun and so
i just sort of had this beet red face that just
started in the middle of the day to make things
worse benzac also has microsponge technology so
it's got like little white bits in it and i had
tiny little white flecks all over my face as well
it was a disaster so after trying to make that
work for a few days i think i abandoned it and i
just went off and ordered 2.5% benzoyl peroxide
from acne.org acne.org is a website started by a
guy who had bad acne and he made his own products
because he just found them so difficult to
find and 2.5% benzoyl peroxide is like the
cornerstone product so his version was really
good it was pretty cheap it had a decent texture
and the only problem was that it took a while to
ship to me which was why i started with the benzac
this worked quite well but it did sort of dry the
crap out of my face benzoyl peroxide is really
good at reacting with dyes and breaking them up
and that causes things to bleach these days there
are lots of benzoyl peroxide washes available and
i would go with one of them instead because you
can wash it off and so less of it ends up on your
towels and on your clothes and on your pillowcase
so that takes me to uni and the end of my teenage
years i still hadn't worked out a skincare routine
by that point and honestly i didn't really
get anywhere with my skincare until i was
around 21 or 22 and even then
it took me a few years to get
the hang of how to give myself a skincare routine
so it took me till my mid to late 20s to really
understand my skin and be able to predict
which products would actually work well for it
my excuse is that we didn't really have the
resources that we do now we didn't have skin
care on youtube the only place you could really
find good information was the paula's choice
website also notice the distinct lack of sunscreen
in my routine i didn't really start trying to wear
it till my mid-20s and even then it took me a few
years to get consistent with wearing it every day
so i hope you enjoyed this throwback episode let
me know if you recognize any of these products or
if you use them and if not what were the iconic
products that you used in your teenage years
i'm going to post a routine that i
wish i had when i was a teenager soon
so subscribe and click the nerdification
bell for that you can also follow me on
instagram and tiktok and check out my blog
for more see you next time for more science